uh anyone who's got my book it will say
don't go backwards to go forwards but
some people don't understand that
if I go here
get it out
and do it then it's okay but I've
actually use that with strength
there's another one that Nick was
showing if I if I do go up
and take it then it's basic because I've
got one hand on it but what am I going
to do now
it just it just come from that height
it went that high now it's back to this
height where's it going to go again
you know
look I know you're a prized fight when
you're in the street and you've had too
many drinks but can you give me half an
hour because I need this technique
you ain't you haven't got I've been in
real situations and you don't it's
milliseconds you've got milliseconds
that's that technique you was doing
I can't lift it up lower it down I can't
do anything more so where does it come
from
foreign
so you can see
this hand
so now we've got two techniques that
look exactly the same
I don't know what foot he's got forward
so I could be like this but it would
help if I'm in hand me but I could be
like this because I don't know what foot
he's got forward I have to choose what
way I'm going to go
so I'm going to go this way or this way
this way or this way how am I going to
lift my arms up I can't lift them up so
I leave them where they are
I take it out I leave him where he is
I step out here we're back to almost now
katatadori if you think about it and
then I'll push him down
so I've now got two techniques that I
don't have to worry about oh how many
techniques we've got to remember because
I'm starting to piece them together
slowly
if I if I
do this
and that
from usherdo
I can't bring it I can't bring it up but
I can leave it there and I can move my
buttock to my hand my buttock to my hand
okay and then you know the rest
okay
on a gas mask